could you tell when Chappell was young
that he would turn into the mature funny
comic that he is today you can't he
wasn't fully realized that's it wasn't
fully realized but he was brilliant he
had like whole bits that were pretty
that were already genius at seven here
yeah you could tell that he'd become
something I mean it's not like I knew
he'd be who you know but I'm not
surprised
are there comics that you met when you
were young that you said this person is
going to be like a comet like a
lightning bolt in comedy and then they
kind of don't go anywhere oh yeah lots a
lot right yeah like I knew guys from
radio who were really good and then you
just never heard from him again there
are people that own it I try to explain
to people no no you don't understand
everyone worshipped him
he was the king like you know and what
goes wrong are some people just not
likable no it's not that I think it's so
many comics
are their own worst enemies how you know
that I mean well what do you mean in
other words they they drink too much or
do too many drugs some things just a
fear of failure so they don't try so
they sabotage themselves drink or get
high before you know they don't they
don't they don't go for their fullest
potential because that risks too much or
something I don't know like wouldn't it
be a great comedy special if if we sarah
silverman presents guys she knows who
should be famous but never became famous
I would watch that oh my god do we like
that idea I do but it's like a lot of
them they're not it's because they're
not they haven't written a joke since
1989 is that right yeah you mean some
people give up to the point where they
have a great act and then they lose
their motivation and they just write out
that act it's like you know how it's
incredible when somebody is a great
musician songwriter and they can sing
yes insane to have all three of those
things right effective right and it's
like with comics it's like you have to
love doing what you do and actually do
it man like you can't just like like no
lazy you think that goes that skates by
for when you're naturally funny you can
be lazy at first but eventually you
gotta get your [ __ ] together and work
it's you know you think they have lack
motivation or something there's some
people who work so hard here when you
read a Steve Martin's book and who is
naturally found I mean right but when
you read that book you see how hard he
worked at it that's what you're talking
about
and it's he is as easily as funny right
now as he ever was yeah I mean naturally
funny when I talked to him I go that's
so funny why doesn't he just write that
down or something I can tell you I had a
sialic I witnessed Steve Martin in the
moment brilliant moment I was this is
very named Robbie but I because we did
um you know one of those AFI honours we
did it for Steve Martin I did that and
then also for Diane Keaton so afterwards
we all went to Steve's house just a few
people very intimate I mean I was
like dying you know like um it's a
special moment you go I've arrived in
Candice Bergen was there and and Diane
Keaton who is like a fabulous actress
died amazing Nancy Meyers and then of
course Martin Jordan Seymour anyway
Martin Short kind of becomes like the
host and asks questions to get
conversation started and he said Candace
when did you first meet Steve and Karen
discuss
I remember I was hanging out with Lorne
and Paul and Steve didn't know what
prosciutto was and then Steve right then
goes can you believe it and now I Drive
one
[Laughter]